anne heisha's hit-and-run investigation
continues
the lapd confirms to et they were
investigating the actress for being
under the influence when she was
speeding down the street and crashed her
car into a nearby home
vehicle into a structure we also have a
structured fire two-story single family
dwelling heavy smoke showing keep
everybody coming
the lapd told et they obtained a warrant
to draw ends blood at the scene and the
results are in authorities confirmed to
e.t narcotics were found in anne's
system at the time of the near fatal car
wreck and haiti is now being
investigated for felony traffic dui ann
heyche is facing a multitude of charges
assuming that the toxicology reports
would come back in her favor i still
think she's facing at least a
hit-and-run charge and a reckless charge
since narcotics can include both cocaine
and fentanyl investigators say
additional testing is required to rule
out additional substances administered
at the hospital
and remains in extreme critical
condition after driving her mini cooper
at an extremely high speed into a home
which ignited a fire that left her with
severe burns
they're going to
remove the body from the free vehicle
and probably transport the victim
to a hospital
earlier this week her rep told et she's
in a coma and has not regained
consciousness
while anne remains hospitalized e.t is
learning more about the projects she
filmed prior to the wreck we're just
praying for her recovery anne's girl in
the room 13 director elizabeth rome is
sending her well wishes before the crash
the actress was working on the passion
project which addresses human sex
trafficking at a tca panel discussion
for the film lifetime exec amy winter
addressed anne's condition and recalled
her performance being so painful and so
riveting something her colleagues
reiterated i know all of us at lifetime
myself larissa everybody is
devastated we are praying for her and
the victims of this
horrible tragedy and
i know that anne really really was
passionate about this film she gave it
everything that she had she brought a
phenomenal performance and force
to this project and
you know she was really committed to
stopping violence against women lifetime
confirms anne's health status will not
affect production since the movie is
already finished it's set to air in
september
[Music]
you